hello everybody hope that you are good
well I got a new microphone so I hope
that you can hear me better this time
and it's been a while since I didn't
post a video on YouTube but I hope that
now with the new microphone if
everything is okay I can post videos
more regularly but anyway yesterday on
the Bitcoin Su the update on X I talked
a lot about my thoughts about what I see
in the chart and I want this video to be
a follow-up video about yesterday so of
course we going to talk about some of
the same things that I talked yesterday
but I also want to try to find something
new in the chart so when I do this
analysis the first thing that comes to
my mind is the daily time
frame why well simply because in the
daily time frame we can see a very clear
range that has been going on for three
months already well a bit more than
three months and you have the range
highs range lows and we also have a very
strong resistance right here you can see
how many times we've been testing it as
resistance okay four times four times in
total all right so uh for some people
this might be the the the range size
this is strong resistance to me to me
the range size is basically the first
high or yeah the first high that we set
in this structure so to me the range
size are going to be in this area okay
you can see here also how we tested a
resistance again but again if you want
to use this strong resistance as the
range size it's fine because since it's
a strong resistance it's going to play
out for your um technical analysis now
the problem comes when you use the the
mid-range because here I want to have a
problem okay the problem that we're
going to have is that if I use my range
SI you can see that we are testing right
now resistance however if you use this
strong resistance at range SI
it's a whole different story we are at
support so I wouldn't play um I wouldn't
take this into consideration really the
mid-range um that's why I'm not playing
with it because since it's true that
technically the range Highs are higher
at up here but this is strong resistance
is also a very important level in the
chart so uh that's why I'm not really
playing with the mid-range because there
is a bit of confusion there and uh it's
something that really I'm I'm not
interested in also another thing I want
to mention my indicator is pretty much
ready you can see also how it doesn't
take any time to to load is very fast
and it's um basically we have I think
four indicators in one we have the the
50 ma that of course you can also change
to any time frame we have the multi-
time frame setting and basically the
priority of this indicator is to Mark
the liquidity pools and the wigs
automatically of course it's not perfect
we're going to need more more testing
this is the version one I'm sure there
is going to be new versions as we
continue using it and setting the
feedback but it's looking good to be
honest and also it works in all the time
frames in all the assets it works in
crypto it works in the stock market it
works in Commodities it works everywhere
so it's quite interesting for example
here in the daily time frame is us that
we have a liquidity pool below us um
that's what I don't like that we are
right now below the daily 50 ma also
we're testing at that resistance if you
notice one two three candlesticks so in
my opinion and this is not Financial
advice this is just me telling you how
I'm playing this I'm not opening any new
Longs until we recover the daily
15a because as long as we don't recover
the daily 50ma and we do something like
this okay I push above it
a retrace tested now support inad
instead of resistance and then you can
start to see Bitcoin going higher maybe
attacking this week here okay but until
that doesn't
happen we could continue testing the
daily 15f resistance and then dropping
towards this liquidity pool so that's
why I'm not opening any Longs at the
moment I'm waiting okay for Longs I'm
not in a rush so what would I go a long
position right now when the daily time
frame is telling me that we have a
problem okay now also if you go into the
8 hours time
frame you can see here indicator working
again uh this is something that I
mentioned in the in yesterday's Bitcoin
date and to be honest it's something
that I wouldn't have noticed if it
wasn't for for this indicator um it was
this week here in the 8 hours time frame
and I said in yesterday's update okay I
think that the first thing the first
level that they're going to attack this
week is going to be at least the 50% of
the week okay and that's at 65,000 560 I
think that last night yeah 8 hours ago
CU I had around 8 hours as sleep nice um
we were a $1,000 s we were at 66 to5 but
I think that the first level we're going
to recovered this week is going to be at
least the 50% of the week and if we
don't see a bounce
or a reaction at this level then
hopefully we can see that the 100% of
the week but a drop below this level if
we drop below this level below the 100%
of the week or we been consolidate here
like this then it's very likely that we
go
lower and we retrace this liquid pool
that goes all the way to 62,000 okay on
the daily time frame I think that's
around 61,000 something but uh that's
pretty much everything that I want to
say so yes the a hours time frame is
playing quite important role right now
okay now let me remove the indicator
let's go to the 4H hour time
frame um if that's the case that we can
see a reaction at the 50% of the week or
the 100% of the week then we could
potentially see here A W pattern okay
something like
this but again that's an if okay for
that we need to see some kind of Bounce
or reaction at the 50% or at the 100% of
the week so that would be something that
I would like to see and if we see
something like this
okay and then let me let me get the
indicator again let me take the 50 ma in
the daily time
frame so it's arounded okay now if we
see this double View button forming out
here at the bottom and we I'm not first
of all I'm not looking for wrongs in
this area that's the first thing okay my
Longs are going to be
here okay this going to be my Longs I'm
going to wait for this push up and then
the retrace to the Daily 50 Ma I want a
candle
closing on let me remove this a candle a
daily candle closing back above the
daily 50a that's when the chart is going
to tell me okay there is possibility for
continuation to the upside look at these
liquidity pools that we have above okay
we have one two three liquidity pools
right above us so uh that's going to be
my long entry um if I well if he if he
gives me the entry all right I want to
keep this video nition and short and I
also want to show you the indicator I
think it's I think it's looking great to
be honest from my point of
view um I'm very happy with it so um if
you're interested in getting the
indicator remember well I've said
yesterday on Twitter also on the
telegram Channel but at the end of this
month I'm going to give access to around
1,300 people 1,500 people and it's 1,000
or
1,100 all the students from the course
Counting previous students so all the
students from the course are going to
get access to the indicator and then
also some active Traders using my X
referral link so I'll leave you the
links in the description also if you use
X you get a 10% discount on trading
fees um we're pushing some bonus
campaigns too so you can get two in one
you know you can get indicator and also
some bonuses if you register and yeah I
think it's a nice way to uh so gratitude
towards that part of my community that H
is supporting my content and
also to get some very good feedback from
the courses students because at the end
all I want here is to test indicator I
need people to test the indicator so we
can share feedback uh between us and
then improve the indicator okay and
maybe hopefully we can get to release
that to the public all right so um
that's pretty much everything guys thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you l